sa force et d'apprendre les coutumes
d'un top qui nous rejetons pour toi
flora est une série troublante est vrai
des survivants des pensionnats
autochtones était visiblement ému après
avoir vu des deux premiers épisodes je
suis
vraiment touché dans la foulée même si
venus me chercher à l'intérieur et
maintenant pour guérir j'ai choisi de
raconter une autre histoire pour toi
flora est le récit de deux enfants
anishinabe enlevé en 1960 et placé dans
un pensionnat autochtone de l'abitibi
témiscamingue cette fiction a été écrite
et réalisée par la cinéaste mois qu
sonia bonche il boit l'eau les racines
de l'histoire de porto flare a fait ça
vient de ma famille moi mon grand-père
et ce toutes ces salles sont allés dans
un pensionnat ça l'à beaucoup affecté ma
famille toutes mes questions
identitaires quand je 36 le pense et
s'efface pas parce que tu as décidé d'en
parler dans une chute n'est facile
l'accès inspirées de divers témoignages
la série met en scène rémi et flora qui
sont frères et soeurs il revisite cette
enfance qu'on leur a volé ni choisi la
guérison
laura est dans le mensonge
on peut pas demander à flora d'être
rendue au même endroit où est rendue
rémy et un moment donné dans la série il
y aurait une rencontre entre rythmiques
au premier matin dans ce bâtiment
bizarre avec des allers retours entre le
passé le présent le tour de force de
cette série est de mettre le doigt sur
les préjugés encore bien présent dans
les soupers de famille moi je me suis
dit je ne me limiterai pas dans ce que
je vais mettre dans tout ce que j'ai
entendu comme préjugés
je vais le mettre parce que ça existe je
l'entends chant suis consciente
dans cette série il est aussi question
du rôle joué par l'église andré
robitaille incarne le père bédard un
personnage complexe pourquoi j'ai dit
oui parce que ok c'est là que vous
mettez une petite musique zoom in ça va
être prétentieux mais j'ai envie de
changer le monde
à coup d'aile de papillon c'est sûr
pour toi flora sera disponible en ligne
sur l'extra d'ici tout point tv de ce
jus dit une série est essentielle et qui
nous met face à notre ignorance une
image à la fois
espérons que ce avoir envoyé le message
recevoir caen mâcon a vécu paix qui on
est ce qui est important messieurs c'est
que ça sert ça se connaissent l'histoire
des pensionnats indiens au canada je
sais que j'ai failli à ma promesse je te
demande pardon ici les prix mais
radio-canada moria
[Musique]